We are setting off on a journey fraught with dangerous notions--
eternity, the creation of all things from nothing, and
dare I utter it, a word not to be thrown around with reckless abandon among those of reason,
infinity.
A case in point -- the library of
Babel.
It is a library that holds every book that has ever been written and every book that ever will be written.
Now here lies the madness: each book is filled with random strings of letters,
26 letters, commas, periods, spaces.
And each book is different, but every volume in every one of these galleries has
410 pages.   Each page has 40 lines. Each line has 80 letters ex-alias,
that is to nothing but chance.
So for every sensible line of straightforward statement, there are leagues and leagues
and leagues
of senseless
jumbles, and incoherences.
For example, one volume is made up in its entirety of the letters
M C V perversely repeated from the first line
to the last.
Another is mostly filled with gibberish until you reach the next to last page, when you see
Oh time thy
pyramids.
It is unbearable knowledge that in some gallery on some shelf, a precious
cogent book exists yet remains inaccessible.
And though one cannot know, my belief is the library stretches to - dare I say it -
the infinite.
Many say I'm mistaken, that the possible number of books does have a limit, and while that number is beyond my understanding
I am gladdened by its distant  Hope  that however improbable, I may one day uncover
Meaning.